what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so as you guys will have noticed with
the Incredible Hulk we kind of kicked
off this run so to speak you know with
with the world war hulk whatev story
where you killed all those superheroes
and became a Herald of Galactus I've
been wanting to do Incredible Hulk stuff
but what I was trying to figure out was
would you guys be likely to just watch a
video that starts a series on Incredible
Hulk or do I just kind of have to like
grab your attention because that's kind
of how it is in YouTube these days for
those you guys who don't know so as you
guys will have noticed with The
Incredible Hulk
we we kind of kicked off this run with
the Incredible Hulk killing all the
superheroes and becoming Galactus Herald
and and that was really the story that I
chose to see whether or not it was
possible to initiate a series of videos
based on the Incredible Hulk going from
Planet Hulk up until the current day
when Bruce banners replaced by Amadeus
Cho I've been wanting to do the same
thing with Thor and I was debating on
going back and forth between like Thor's
origin story like his new origin story
or something that would be more likely
to catch your all's attention and of
course with YouTube being how it is the
fact that videos show up and people
watch you know videos at a mile a minute
um I kind of figured out how to do
something that would basically grab your
attention right off the bat and that's
what I'm hoping this does this is
effectively the story of Wolverine and
for fighting one another now the cool
thing about this is that this is a
digital exclusive and what this means is
that this is one only available online
and two it's self-contained that's one
of the cool things about digital
exclusives sometimes they tie into an
event but almost almost rarely does that
ever happen instead digital exclusives
are designed to be self-contained
stories and they're usually pretty small
like this one is in three parts but is
eight pages each and so it's effectively
a one-shot split into three parts the
reason why this is done in a lot of ways
is because when people get on and they
start reading cover books digitally it's
very easy for individuals to lose
attention and so these stories have to
be written and released in a way to
where they're just long enough to
maintain your attention but also have
content that can keep you coming back
and so by releasing them in you know
three little eight-page segments it's
just enough to keep your attention and
then if you want more you can go see
more if you don't want more well then
you just spent five minutes reading a
comic and that's about it you know but
the cool thing about this though is it
also answers a few questions and what I
mean by that is a lot of people I've
seen a lot of different arguments about
this you know who would win in a fight
Thor or wool
not only that how does adamantium stack
up against uber metal which is the
material that's used to forge sources of
forged Thor's hammer there we go um but
we're actually gonna get into this here
in a minute just because of the fact
that if there's a couple special things
about Thor's hammer that you don't
normally find a new room Edel but this
story is actually written by Frank
Thierry and what this does is it
initially just kind of picks up with
Wolverine where he's basically passed
out in a bar now we wouldn't normally
consider to the business consider this
to be abnormal for Wolverine I cannot
talk today but when he comes to what is
abnormal is that he basically has Lady
Deathstrike standing over him and so
because of this his initial thought is
aren't Lady Deathstrike trying to kill
me like she she is trying to do me in
yet again now again you know Wolverines
response here is par for the course
in the sense that whenever it is that he
comes across his villains the villains
attack him for only one of two reasons
either it's because they have just a
hatred form or because they've been
contracted to do so but it's almost
never been a circumstance where
Wolverine is confronted by a villain and
they're able to basically go their own
separate ways it's usually that they
fight you know and one of them is trying
to kill Wolverine and so ultimately if
the villain lives is because Wolverine
allowed them to live and basically
walked away that's usually what happens
in his stories granted it's a way to
keep those villains coming back but it's
kind of what you run into you when you
have a character like Wolverine who's so
violent and so dangerous and so on but
of course using his sense of smell he
also comes to the realization that lady
death strikes not the only one there
that we've also got Omega Red probably
his most formidable villain since he has
the ability to basically neutralize
Wolverines healing factor for a short
amount of time we've got mr. sinister
we've got neo Bastian mystique so on
this is a huge kind of you know roster
of his most notable foes that are going
against him but the the real kicker here
is that he's met by the arrival of
Sabretooth now the reason why this
matters is because Wolverine killed
Sabretooth and I think I might cover
that story in the future once we get
closer to the release of the Logan film
but Wolverine killed Sabretooth and so
to see him come back kind of blows his
mind you know he's like where where did
you come from because last I remember I
cut your head off so I don't understand
why you're here right now more so than
that who's Sabretooth is well I would
say Omega Red is a little more dangerous
Omega Red doesn't come around that
often so if you were talking about like
the most dangerous consistent villain of
Wolverine
it would probably be Sabretooth just
because of the fact that Sabretooth is
just as agile he's just as good of a
fighter he's almost as capable as
Wolverine is in virtually every sense
and because of that you know he's one of
the most notable and if I were the
original villain for Wolverine and
because of this is essentially his his
worst foe coming back to life the
problem with this is that Wolverine is
like okay I got to get out of here and I
got to regroup because the other thing
about this Wolverine is basically
surrounded by all of his villains in the
same place I mean apocalypse the whole
nine yards and so his idea is okay we'll
get out of here we'll rethink the
situation come back kill them all and
then finish my beer the problem is when
he gets out we realized these aren't his
villains instead it's Thor who
apparently looks like Sabretooth and
just regular individuals who were here
and so Thor comes to the realization
that if Wolverines not stopped because
he's having a hallucination he's been
led to believe that all of his villains
have returned he's basically gonna go on
a killing spree now the cool thing about
this was by Thierry is he's actually
drawing in a few different sources here
he's drawing in a few different things
the most notable of these is enemy of
the state now enemy of the state was one
of the really really popular Wolverine
stories and that's kind of way goes to
this character because of the fact that
Wolverine is basically just a guy that
goes through an attack stuff that's all
he really does but finding good stories
or consistently good stories is a really
difficult thing to do but when you find
them they're really something to behold
enemy of the state was a story where
Wolverine was basically kidnapped and
brainwashed by the combined efforts of
Hydra and the hand of course Hydra being
a break off from the traditional Nazi
Germany party that was led by Baron von
Strucker they were part science part
let's take over the world the hand was
the mystical Japanese organization that
used magic and Wizardry in conjunction
with things like resurrection and so on
to achieve a multitude of goals
mostly operating from the shadows but
with these two groups working together
which they've done before but with these
two groups working together they
basically turned Wolverine into a
killing machine to the point that he was
a literal one-man army
facing off against the Marvel Universe
now he was stopped but in the story that
I did
Wolverine kills the Marvel Universe that
answered the question of what would have
happened if he wasn't stopped and it
just led to him killing all the
superheroes on earth in a way that was
very similar to old man Logan with
regards to him killing the x-men but the
idea here is afraid here is kind of
invoking this with a sense that Thor
sits down as
look if Wolverines non-stop it could
lead to another enemy of the state kind
of situation and so we've got to bring
him to and we've got to get him out of
whatever hallucination he's having and
we have to bring him back to reality now
where Thor is following his tracks and
at least locates where the tracks stop
of course he's ambushed by Wolverine but
what Frank Thierry does is he answers
the question here's how Wolverine stands
in regards to Thor both by way of
adamantium as well as its fighting style
in terms of who would win now this comes
from Thor's mouth so to speak in terms
of how Frank Terry's riding him so you
know take it for what it's worth but in
terms of adamantium versus zuru metal
when Wolverine ambushes Thor he goes to
basically slashes hammer and doesn't
damage it now there are a couple reasons
for this one the fact that the hammer is
made of uber metal but - this is not
just any form of uber metal Thor's
hammer is basically designed in a way to
where it's amplified by magic and so it
effectively makes the hammer stronger as
time goes on the problem with this is
that Wolverine having true adamantium is
supposed to be the hardest metal in the
Marvel Universe and so it's kind of like
this unstoppable force meeting an
immovable object if Wolverines true
adamantium is the hardest and most
durable metal in the universe then how
is it a Thor's hammer can stack up
against it well what Marvel says is they
say well it's just enchantment its
Asgardian magic it's basically the fact
that this thing has been enchanted over
and over again it's been you know seen a
multitude of battles because of this
it's just a special kind of metal and in
a sense it's basically unbreakable it's
indestructible now when I say
indestructible I do mean that it's
indestructible against like physical
objects but for example molecule man
Owen Reese was able to destroy the
hammer by breaking it down on the
molecular level and so that is kind of
goes to the fact that it really takes a
reality warper to basically destroy
Thor's hammer but at the very least it
shows us that when it comes to you know
true adamantium versus uber metal that
true adamantium just doesn't win out
here that uber metal seems to be able to
take the cake now the question we have
to ask and this is a question that's not
answered here is if wolverine sat one of
his claws or put one of his claws on the
edge of a table and then Thor would have
hit his hand with a hammer when it
caused the car to break in half is that
possible can uber metal basically
destroy adamantium that question was
actually answered in a different story I
don't know brought my
which one it was but Thor actually
started smashing adamantium with his
hammer and was able to dent it and so it
seems like from what Marvel's saying
they're more or less equivalent you know
they seem to be equal in their own
former fashion that one's not stronger
than the other is basically you know to
equal objects smashing into each other
so it creates this kind of weird
situation here but the idea is that you
know again as the two of them are going
against one another as they're fighting
Wolverine just doesn't seem to be able
to snap out of this he doesn't seem to
be able to grasp everything that's going
on and so what Thor says is Wolverines
fighting style is prodigious in terms of
his you know his stance in combat his
ruthlessness his speed this is basically
Thor saying that when it comes to
hand-to-hand combat he cannot keep up
with Wolverine this because of the fact
that while Wolverines claws don't really
damage Thor as easily as it would a
normal person
his Klaus will kill Thor and so if Thor
doesn't find a way to counter Wolverines
movements Wolverine will kill him and so
that's that's effectively Frank Thierry
saying when it comes to traditional
hand-to-hand combat Thor cannot win
against Wolverine and so what Thor does
is he basically smashes the ground with
his hammer
you know sins will reign into a reverie
and then calls down lightning and
basically you know strikes will rain
with it to the point that it knocks
Wolverine out of his hallucination and
so because of this you know Wolverine
comes to the realization okay I probably
should have figured out that Sabretooth
wielding a hammer and calling down
lightning and flying was an indication
this was not Sabretooth but for whatever
reason he didn't and so once the two of
them you know begin putting their own
noggins to use so to speak it's
essentially then coming to the
realization that Loki is behind all this
now this actually has a really funny
ending to be honest like I really love
the way the story has a way Frank here
he does this but what he does is he
wraps back around and he says that you
know Wolverine had basically been going
through Oklahoma he was in Oklahoma
heard a lot of weird things that were
taking place out there and decided to
investigate it and so once he went to
this bar you know looked around to
figure out if this was something that
the Avengers need to be a part of that
he you know went into the bar he got a
drink from the barkeep only to pass out
and we learned that the barkeep was
actually Loki and so because of this
this is why Wolverine had basically
collapsed at the beginning of this story
leading to Thor getting involved and so
once Thor is like okay you know we got
to find a way to stop Loki then there's
suddenly attacked there's suddenly
ambushed by all these different villains
and it's actually really cool because a
lot of them are villain
that are inherent to Thor himself so
like to destroy your armor enchantress
Valkyrie or at least people who were
villains at one point there's a version
of Thor in the back it's it's kind of
cool here to see him going against these
different foes the funny thing about
this though is that as Wolverine and for
fight them each time they basically hit
them they essentially turn to dust and
they they basically fall away because
they were never really here in the first
place and so once Thor and a Wolverine
come to this realization that none of
these guys are really here their next
step is okay let's go find Loki
well then Thor's like hey man sometimes
there is no great big scheme like
sometimes it's not Loki doing some huge
scheme sometimes Loki does things
because he's Loki and so what for a key
area is telling us here is that
initiating this whole conflict forcing
Wolverine to hallucinate his villains
having him go against Thor wasn't
because Loki was trying to take over the
world it wasn't because Loki wanted to
kill for it at that point in time it was
really just because Loki felt like being
a dick that was really just the reason
why he did this that's it it was just
Loki just being Loki for a short amount
of time but that's why I say you know
these these things are these little
digital excuses are cool because they're
self-contained and they usually have
pretty fun stories you know they usually
have pretty fun endings I thought this
story was really fun I had a great time
reading it but um but yeah you know it's
just it answers a few questions you know
one of the things that again people
always want to know was like adamantium
versus Thor's hammer how does that work
out you know that kind of thing but um
any but if you guys are new here to
comics explain like she hit the sub
button to become part of the rock port
and depending on how this video is
received what we might do is we might
turn what is today Tuesday we might turn
Tuesday or whatever day this video comes
out we might turn that in like a Thor
day and we just start covering for from
the time he came back after Ragnarok up
until the current day so you guys can
basically follow the Thor chronology and
be caught up in what's going on right
now with like unworthy Thor and Jane
Foster Thor and all that kind of good
stuff
and all the things that led up to it so
if you guys like that idea if you guys
want to see more for stuff to make sure
you guys drop a like and leave a comment
down below let me know what you guys
think and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]